bonsoir vous connaissez tous le monde
bonjour chanteuse michelle blanc
l'acteur en blond il erra dix ans aussi
mathieu qui va remplacer bertrand
delanoë à la mairie 2008 et peut-être
vous ne connaissez pas m'aider à
marinescu qui est une star roumaine qui
est excellente dans le film d'isabelle
mergault qui s'appelle je vous trouve
très beau
voilà elle est formidable elle ressemble
à l'égérie de fellini du lait à damas
c'est vrai la salle les yeux ronds
adorent aller au même
oui mais ta gueule c'est triste mais
c'est trop je suis pas capable il te dis
ta gueule je t'ai pas dit que tu as les
couilles tu es castratrice coup tu sais
quoi personne ne te crois bon muriel
mien bonsoir alors vous êtes écrivain ou
écrivaine écrivain parce que vous
préférez écrivain c'est comme un plus
joli moi alors j'ai été révélée à 23 ans
par un livre intitulé lentilles voyage
qui était le récit d'un périple de deux
ans en orient j'ai été découverte par
roger caillois salué par max pol fouchet
et encensé par andré malraux et a dit
vous possédez un don des dieux le talent
narratif
ensuite après d'anti voyage il ya une
trentaine de romans dont le diable vert
une passion les rois et les voleurs
maria tieffenthal heures et c est ce qui
est incroyable avec vous une réelle
servent c'est qu'en mars 2004 vous
témoigner dans marie claire
un article où étaient liés ou d'ailleurs
sur la violence conjugale vous raconter
comment votre compagnon avait voulu vous
tuer en 2001 est aujourd'hui très
bizarrement vous publiez un livre chez
écriture qui s'appelle bertrand cantat
ou le chant des automates et vous lui
donnez dans ce bouquin pratiquement
l'absolution sévère simplement il ya des
femmes qui sont victimes de harcèlement
moral
chaque jour ou chaque jour on les
diminue on les rabats ce sont les petits
mots assassins comme on dit vous savez
les mots suffisent souvent
et puis aussi un type qui peut
s'emporter qui peut être drogué je peux
arriver par votre hobby qui peut émettre
passion quelqu'un qui se refuse un peu à
lui qui dit moi ne veut pas lui parler
c'est ce que j'explique un petit peu
dans mon livre car j'ai essayé d'être un
peu voyante c'est mon métier sinon je ne
sais pas en voyant je n'écrirai pas et
qui soudain coup donc effectivement
s'emporte et des visages des figures
c'est drôle un seul titre de l'album de
comptes à des figures cette fille
bizarre vous avez été victime de
violences conjugales vous même et là
vous essayer de nous convaincre de la
non culpabilité de cantat de la fatalité
de l'acte voire de la responsabilité de
l'entourage
je me demande si vous n'êtes pas à 100
de ce qu'on appelle le syndrome de
stockholm d'accord avec ça je crois
qu'elle est atteinte du syndrome de
stockholm
je veux dire simplement nos amis
téléspectateurs qui ne savent pas que le
syndrome de stockholm c'est quand la
victime tombe amoureuse de son bourreau
tout avoue muriel votre compagnon avait
l'intention de vous briser la nuque sur
les pierres démarche d'un perron il a
été arrêté net par une crise d'épilepsie
dont vous avez les avait quand même
connu ça de très près comment vous
pouvez aujourd'hui faire un livre qui
déculpabilise bertrand cantat c'est ça
que j'essaye de comprendre mais j'ai
fait un livre qui est justement une
espèce de frontières cuisante entre la
vision et se met dans la peau de
quelqu'un qui pour moi que pour moi mais
c'est complètement ma propre vision
a voulu simple un jour fait une erreur
la faute irréparable la chose
impardonnable et la tuer et d'autres
personnes essaient de tuer
minutieusement tous les jours ce sont
des tortures minutieux et c'est cela
donc effectivement que je veux vraiment
dénoncer les autres après tout ça n'est
pas du tout mon problème et quentin
compte tout à fait je me suis dit
bertrand cantat mais bien sûr que c'est
sa faute
j'ai commencé j'entame une
correspondance avec lui je voulais
savoir s'il en était je délègue
bouleversante de ce type il s'en sortira
jamais jamais il a été voir sa femme qui
venait d'accoucher de sa fille alice
alors qu'il était avec marie il était
fou amoureux de marie dont le thème dans
mon livre c'est l'amour passion et
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait qu'est ce qui se
passe avec bon le début de ma
correspondance avec cantat qui a été
arrêté après vilnius parce qu a prévenu
que les trop malade pour correspondre
avec qui que ce soit et nous devions
écrire on s'est à nouveau dit oui parce
qu'ils fort pour préparer un nouveau
disque avec son gros ça sera bien c'est
pas bien sûr muriel ça veut dire qu'ils
arrivent à vivre et on ne lui a pas volé
son amour il a tué bien sûr que l'or
continue pas ça mais sans son accord et
rythmé
il a tué justement dans un geste
complètement en été dans un geste tout
le long posséder avec des substances et
avec des substances 36 coûte anti
facture 36 coups absolument
le visage décomposé comme pour un
accident de moto avec des brûlures aux
jambes et aux cuisses comme quelqu'un
qu'on a traîné pour te mettre dans le
lit avec un appel au frère de marie à
qui il ne dit pas ce qui s'est passé qui
dit que maria
le coc car dira simplement que l'on veut
remettre à plus tard le premier jour de
tournage d'après était une femme qui
meurt doucement d'hémorragie inter c'est
effectivement ce que je dis elle est
morte dans une espèce de règlement et de
nyon qui sait comment il l'a tapée
essayer dès le seul à le savoir
excusez moi c'est vrai que quand quand
on lit vos deux bouquins on sait on voit
pas ça c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression
qu'il donne un coup qui s'emporte c'est
dalkia pas les 36 coups y at il à l
étranger qu en effet car je n'avais pas
la connaissant leur psychologie
simplement les lettres de tandt a oui
les lettres de compta vous savez ce
qu'est vraiment un pervers narcissique
c'est quelqu'un qui sait manipuler un
ordre énorme et ce sont des joueurs de
claquettes
moi je pense que quand quelle place la
mi temps à lire le droit ville de
vilnius lituanien pour comprendre qu'en
effet les substances alcooliques et et
illicites sont absolument des faits
aggravants dans le droit lituanien et
pas dans le droit français parce que
c'est laissé à un jugement du juge
je regrette je dis c'est très très clair
parce que moi aussi j'ai étudié tout ça
c'était très important pour moi et que
donc petit à petit la déposition de
bertrand cantat parce que c'est sa leaf
acte c'est qu'est-ce qu'il a déposée et
comment il a changé de des positions
entre le moment où il a été arrêté
nous avons eu des informations des
médecins de vilnius qui ont dit qu'il
avait pris tous les deux des substances
et tous les deux avaient bu et que quand
il a vu que dans le droit lituanien ce
n'est même pas moi qui le dit c'est
libération il a changé complètement son
discours pour dire qu'il était le mari
avait été la seule à avoir bu avoir
fumer des pétards
excusez moi qu'à un moment et qu'à un
moment elle était parti tout seul
absolument prendre soi disant des choses
dans les toilettes ça ça a été pas dit
au début et ce sont des choses qui ont
été rajoutés au fur et à mesure moi
lui tout le procès j'ai vu un bertrand
cantat se mettre au courant des lois et
petit à petit me dirait des positions et
préparer sa défense ce que je comprends
très bien parce que chacun à son esprit
reptilien et il faut qu'on survivent
maintenant kristina rady c'est la même
chose quand elle est arrivée elle a
raconté les violences qu'elle avait subi
avec bertrand cantat dont elle s'est
rétractée tout de suite après quand elle
a vu tout est à la russe l'a cru
défendre ses enfants moi je ne crois pas
qu'on défend ses enfants contre le
mensonge
moi ce que je sais c'est que marie est
morte avec un visage qui était détruite
comme après un accident de moto eu à 120
à l'heure et ce sont les mots même des
médecins bien alors on va lui aussi très
clair on va avancer un petit peu vous
vous muriel non mais j'essaye de
comprendre comment vous la presse que
vous avez subi comment vous pouvez
défendre encore quentin et et vous dit
en parlant de votre joueur la soupe
bertrand cantat au volant de votre jules
vous dites que vous lui avez pardonné
tout simplement parce que vous ne pouvez
pas imaginer la vie sans lui vous dit
vivre sans lui c'est la mort vivre avec
lui c'est la mort mais peut-être aussi
la vie vous dit
la seule façon qu'il aurait de me tuer
actuellement serait de me quitter
donc finalement et vous préférez rester
avec quelqu'un qui est susceptible de
vous frapper que d'être quitté par cette
personne c'est ça que j'essaye de
comprendre d'eux m'a frappé c'est
quelqu'un qui est très malade dont je
voudrais effectivement obtenir quelque
chose de mieux et une rédemption pour
lui et qu'il aille mieux est quelqu'un
qui supporte mal donc je ne peux pas
quitter quelqu'un qui se porte mal quoi
qu'il me fasse pour l'instant je suis
bien incapable on est bien quelque part
une saison c'est probablement quelque
chose d'assez noble c'est peut-être
parce c'est peut-être quelque part par
là et je ne peux pas moi vie sans
passion je suis désolé je passe je suis
pas là à dire on a frappés on n'a pas
froid oui bien sûr ah si le jour on m'a
vraiment où cet homme pris par une crise
de démence et c'est une effectivement
commencé à sortir des couteaux puis des
pierres à vouloir mettre bien sûr
je vous conseille des cours de karaté
accéléré vous demandez au canada si vous
voulez vous serez au même temps au même
niveau
parce que le problème entre 1h de leur
avait volé quelqu'un qui barrent et de
couple c'est qu'on est au même niveau on
est là on est mené l'explication je
capitule un cri pas et qui était
quelqu'un qui avait un grand talent dans
la musique il n'a pas pu exploiter son
talent qu'est la maladie a pris de vous
même de suisse est super il ne me tape
pas dessus ce n'est pas super justement
il peut être cruel
il peut effectivement il peut exercer
sur man et sa cruauté mentale
tant mieux si vous tue pas mais quand y
tue il est hors la loi mais je pense
qu'on est en la loi dit en avant alors
muriel diallo continue ans quand il vaut
mieux alors pour vous en fait
l'explication que vous donnez du crime
de bertrand cantat l'univers de la
passion est une tuerie par essence
bien sûr l univers de la patience ça
dépend quelle passion et comme on
l'apprend la passion selon le christ
s'est passé là et heureusement et la
passion selon le christ effectivement du
sang oui même si physiquement mais c'est
à lui qu'il avait choisi non mais bien
sûr maintenant est ce que vous aimez
faire mais qu'est-ce que ça non je suis
responsable de ça je pense qu'il a droit
une rédemption
j'ai vraiment envie que bertrand
scousers et consorts deux pays qui sort
de prison
maintenant dire que marie était
responsable de sa mort avec lui que
c'est la passion et l'amour qu'ils ont
tué non l'amour n'apporte pas la mort ou
alors c'est une erreur
je n'ai pas dit ça nous empêche de bien
mais quand ça c'est quelque chose qui
est important est que quand chanteur
hubert félix thiéfaine qui diront jeter
barreau mon ami nous battons dont 2 or
honte à voler ton amour mais qui lui a
volé son [ __ ] d'amour mari est mort
sous ses coups dans un visage tuméfié
il a laissé mourir dans son lit alors
qu'il aurait pu appeler les secours
c'est un manque de compassion terrible
moi j'ai dérangé parce qu'on n'existe
pas sans empathie et sans compassion et
là il y en a pas eu donc c'est la part
du monstre moi je ne condamne pas la
part du monstre je veux que bertrand
s'en sortent
je veux que christina sion sorte et ses
enfants marie elle est morte elle s'en
sortira plus et jean-louis il aura sa
peine emma et est sain et sa femme
nadine elle aura sa peine et son frère
et ses enfants et son fils de 4 ans mais
ressort toujours l'enfer ils sont tous
dans la belle mais y'en a marre qui a
tué vous permet et ça je veux le dire et
le redire encore avec le patch apporte
enceinte et nue entre vous soyez une
rédemption je pense aux verts de sortir
et pour pour muriel et le tentative de
comprendre un peu comme marguerite duras
qui va sur la vologne qui dit sublime
forcément sublime là c'est pas du tout
sublime c'est j'ai souffert je souffre
encore
j'aime encore il ya une espèce de 2 bien
comme ça des liens charnels entre les
gens qui sont des diamants tokyo les un
très fort qu'est ce qu'on peut qu est-ce
qu on peut vraiment savoir est-ce qu'on
peut juger le christ a dit m ton ennemi
est ce qu'on peut juger est ce qu'on
peut juger ont peut-être pas juger mais
en plus complexe processus
est-ce qu'il faut dire qu'il faut des
autres humaniser le monde puis il ya un
film qui va te plaire son fils de
roselyne bosch qui s'appelle animal et
qui dit en fait que si toute cette
violence en arrive pas là à la maîtriser
c'est parce qu'on n'est pas fini on a
encore de voir ce film est génial il est
mort de culpabilité dans les lettres qu
il m'écrit il me dit mais je veux tout
assumer mon devrait jamais sûr dépasser
par les forces pareil mais de ses 16 sur
aucun pont devrait faire ça et ça va de
a à z aurait me dis là je sais pourquoi
z comme ses brûlures enfin on est dans
les temps des choses absolument
terrifiante et cet homme ne vivra plus
comme terrifiant êtes en effet habilitée
à juger par mon dieu oh mon nom
attendait les jus dans la culpabilité et
de son savent à quoi tu sais les lézards
et du manipulateur ce sont des gens
extrêmement intelligent et s'affèrent
l'éclairage est il sincère des
claquettes comme personne au monde jean
kelly à côté des manipulateurs sait rien
du tout les de la main et alors même
gene kelly et fred astaire à côté de
bertrand cantat pour les claquettes
c'est de la merde
bertrand cantat est le meilleur est
meilleur que mal parce que si parce que
ce sont des harceleurs que ce sont des
gens qui ont une autre vie en eux et que
ce qu'il a fait si la et détruit mari
depuis le début en lui des tricheries sa
famille oui j'étais là en les détruisant
son milieu qui était le cinéma en lui
disant que c'est un milieu un milieu de
conte de bourgeois de connards de
protection et lui il était rock'n'roll
le rock'n'roll
fuck parce que le rock'n'roll su c'est
ce que c'est c'est l'industrie les
rappeurs ça comme aussi parce que c'est
eux qui veulent être vizir à la foire du
mans là moi je fais ça moi je dis c'est
ça
berthon comptent à elles deux
rui barclay il ay derrière lui un
million cinq cent mille de disques
vendus et représente une force
commerciale et maintenant moi j'attends
la sortie de bertrand cantat avec un
livre sur marie mon amour mari mon amour
j'espère qu'il aura pas l'audace de le
faire parce que ça ce serait vraiment
vilain et ce serait vraiment horrible
j'espère qu'il aura conscience de l'acte
qu'il a commis en effet il ya les
zébrures ya tout mais il ya des gens qui
se sont sortis des camps de
concentration à leur bertrand cantat il
peut se sortir aussi de son milieu de
son père militaire et de ses douleurs et
moi je trouve qu'une seule chose c'est
que tant que les femmes accepteront
d'être victimes au nom de l'amour c'est
foutu abba bridget jones à batterie
djembé locale brij le jeu bridget jones
je veux déclin la bride lg modo si damas
ne vous oblige à en croire la fontaine
du grand charmont bien réel
est ce que est ce que françoise y avait
quelque chose à ajouter là dessus rien
du tout rire du tout michel ben je pense
que wanda été extrêmement bien placé
pour hélas être très proche de l'horreur
de la chose puisque elle était très ami
avec marie qu'en plus elle travaille
avec elle à ce moment là je n'ai jamais
pu comprendre comment on pouvait en
arriver au cou au nom de quoi que ce
soit mais surtout de la passion et je
pense que puisque tu as parlé tout à
l'heure d'un rapport commun que nous
avons vu j'appellerais plutôt une
histoire d'amour eh bien on s'est
formidablement engueuler à certains
moments jamais ni l'un ni l'autre n'a
porté la main sur l'autre
tu es petit mais si tu avais été et je
crois que c'était très passionnel est
très passionné et c'est pour ça que
c'est un merveilleux souvenir
mais est on aurai je dire on ya des il y
avait des moments de grand affrontement
jamais ni l'un ni l'autre n'a eu la
moindre pulsions de violence ces trucs
aucun match et on peut se raccrocher
psychologiquement maintenant que le mal
est fait c'est que ça puisse sauver
d'autres vies que ça serve d'exemple
pour pour aider des mecs qui ont
vraiment la main leste surprend l'essai
est pardonné peut-être une chose est
d'avoir le dossier pardonner merci à
tous
il n'ya de merci d'avoir été avec l'art
donc pourquoi je recommande ce livre qui
est intéressant par sa bizarrerie comme
j'essayais de le dire ça s'appelle bien
bon tu as tout le champ des automates
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu